fewer and fewer people believe nowadays
it's possible that in a generation there
simply won't be religion across Europe
and large sections of North America
Australia and Asia that's not
necessarily a problem but it's worth
thinking about why people made up
religion in the first place and what
we're doing with the needs and longings
that led them to do so at one level
religions are about asking us to believe
in something
and when people say they can't believe
they tend to stop right there with the
whole religion business and often point
out all the horrid things that religions
have undoubtedly done and continue to do
but in a sense belief is almost the
least important and definitely the least
interesting side of religion
what's fascinating is all the other
stuff religions get up to for example
the way they regularly gather people
around and strikingly tell them to be
nice to one another
or the way they create a sense of
community acting as hosts making sure
the granny and the child the Big Chief
and the little guy learn to see each
other as human beings rather than
abstract entities
religions use rituals to point stuff out
to us and Lodge it in our fickle Minds
for example that the seasons are
changing or that it's the time to
remember your ancestors
that the Moon looks pretty
but you can atone and make a fresh start
or that it's rather amazing there's food
on the table
religions know we're not just
intellectual creatures so they carefully
appeal to us via art and Beauty we think
of Beauty in one category frivolous and
superficial thing and truth and depth in
another religions join them together
they build temples Cathedrals and
mosques that use Beauty to lend depth to
important ideas they use the resources
of art to remind us of what matters
their art is didactic it's directed at
making us feel things
calm
pity or
we may no longer believe but the needs
and longings that made us make up these
stories go on
we're lonely and violent we long for
beauty wisdom and purpose we want to
live for something more than just
ourselves
Society tells us to direct our hopes in
two areas
romantic love and professional success
and it distracts us with news movies and
consumption it's not enough as we know
especially at three in the morning we
need reminders to be good places to
reawaken or something to awaken our
Kinder less selfish impulses Universal
things which need tending like delicate
flowers and rituals that bring us
together
the choice isn't between religion and
the secular world as it is now the
challenge is to learn from religions so
we can fill the secular world with
replacements for the things we long ago
made up religion to provide
the challenge begins here